I think you're really gonna like this
one lera Trump lera Trump is
daughter-in-law of Donald Trump's I
guess she must be married to Eric Trump
because Don Jr is divorced and dating
one of the former Fox News ladies I
believe in any case lera Trump goes on
Fox News she goes on Fox News to be
interviewed about the Trump Syria Kurds
fiasco now before we even look at what
she said why would you interview not
even the son of Trump or the daughter of
Trump but Trump's kids wife about Syria
when her background has nothing to do
with anything that would make her have
an informed position on Syria her
background is a story producer on
television I don't know why you
interview Lara Trump about Syria to
begin with but let's not focus on that
right now because that'll get us
off-track okay Fox News says we thought
we've just have to we have to have Lara
Trump on and talk to her about Syria and
the Kurds okay Larry Trump defends
Donald Trump's harebrained and
completely disastrous actions in Syria
by saying effectively the average
American is ignorant so there she
explains that listen most Americans
don't even know who the Kurds are Trump
was right which if you understand
not even formal logic but just in a
colloquial sense how you put an argument
together doesn't really compute as an
argument check out the video and imagine
the dystopia we're living in
we're number one the president's
daughter-in-law is making a political
political analysis of what's going on in
the Middle East despite it having
nothing to do whatsoever with her
background or area of expertise and
imagine that it counts as political
analysis to defend a policy by saying
there are lots of ignorant Americans and
given an unanticipated victory - for
American adversaries Russia Iran the
Syrian government and the Islamic state
your response tonight well Shannon I
think we should start with the fact that
if you ask the average American out
there I think they would have to Google
who are the Kurds and why is America
even over there fighting this war we
were supposed to be there for 30 days
we've been there for 10 years and when
the president campaigned in 20
sixteen he was very clear that he wanted
to stop all of these endless wars that
he wanted to bring our troops back home
that's right Shannon what do I think
about a thoughtful piece in the New York
Times
seriously assessing the grave nature of
what's been done here the history the
geopolitics and other considerations
what I think is that the average
American has no idea who the Kurds are
oh and so then what she also tells lies
we were supposed to be there thirty days
she says that's not true
there was no such deadline established
at the time now that might have been a
mistake you can say there should have
been a deadline established at the
beginning but there was no such deadline
established at the beginning she says
we've been there ten years it's 2019
that would mean 2009 Obama first
committed troops in 2015 you can
disagree with the decision but you don't
get to measure time in some different
way that's four to five years ago you
could be overly charitable and say well
the Obama decision really was linked to
the coalition that first went in in 2014
like okay maybe you stretch it to 2014
but these are just lies it's lie after
lie after lie and it's an example of the
self-reinforcing feedback loop of
ignorance that we have in this country
understand how it works you have rampant
ignorant and a total lack of critical
thinking skills in some states like
Texas it's by design because they've
decided we are not going to teach
critical thinking in schools we're not
gonna teach philosophy in schools we're
not going to build the base of the
knowledge pyramid as I described it that
prepares people to really critically
think about the messages that they're
getting in media so you get that then
you get those clueless people that lack
those skills brought on to do political
analysis and using the fact that there
are ignorant Americans to justify the
terrible policies of an administration
so what is implied by Larry Trump's
comment is that since many Americans
don't know who the Kurds are what
concern about them as disingenuous
concern trolling because nobody even
knows who they
our does she mean that since lots of
Americans don't know who the Kurds are
you can't possibly care about people you
don't personally know I mean sadly that
is an unfortunate reality in the
American right wing is more than we'd
like to admit we have so many of these
stories of virulent lis anti-gay
Republicans who once they know someone
who's LGBT a kid a neighbor whatever all
of a sudden they develop an empathy and
an understanding for what's going on she
may actually be right as a right winger
which I guess she is I don't know she
might be saying I don't understand how
anyone could even feign support for
Kurds when they don't even know who they
are because I don't know I never cared
about anybody I didn't meet personally
maybe that's what she means but the
message is sickening which is if
Americans don't know who the Kurds are
we can ignore that they are and have
been our allies they've helped us in the
past they've helped us fight Isis and
Donald Trump said that was one of his
top priorities to fight in to feed Isis
we can ignore all of that if Americans
are simply ignorant to who the Kurds are
really disturbing stuff on so many
levels again that this even counts as a
political analysis is extraordinarily
disturbing that lera Trump would be
asked to comment about Middle East
policy is laughable and maybe more of a
reflection of Fox News than of anything
else and then of course in the end the
fact that it's a ridiculous argument
what does it matter if Americans do or
don't know who the Kurds are I pointed
out on Twitter that there are hangers-on
who without knowing any of the history
are taking hyper-partisan positions on
this one way or the other and that's not
particularly productive but you don't
need to personally know the Kurds in
order to care about the policy that is
going extremely astray by Donald Trump
and coming from the White House and
again who suggested this policy because
it wasn't Trump's generals it wasn't the
Pentagon it wasn't the military we don't
know exactly where or why Donald Trump
came up with this idea let's take a
quick break we have a tremendous program
for you today make sure that you're
following me on Twitter at D Pakman
follow the show
on twitter at david pakman show and
importantly we are back on twitch after
our 24-hour ban at twitch.tv slash david
pakman do-it cappucci paid for de gracia
mila one of our sponsors making the
david pakman show possible is Babel the
language learning app and you'll get 25%
off a subscription to Babel when you
click the link under this video
Babel was founded in 2007 and now has
over a million paying subscribers
worldwide as one of the world's leading
language learning apps their learning
method has been examined numerous times
in scientific studies including one at
Yale in 2019 which found that 100
percent of participants who used Babel
were able to improve their oral
proficiency with a new language within
just three months research found that
users learning Spanish on Babel only
needed to use the app for an average of
15 hours over a two-month period to
cover the requirements for one college
semester of Spanish I recently went to
Italy and used Babel to brush up on my
Italian for a few weeks leading up to
the trip and I was actually surprised at
how much I was able to absorb in such a
short amount of time
after practicing Italian on the babble
app I was able to hold some
conversations with locals in Italy I
could understand a lot more of the
Italian that I was hearing and the
progress I made was extremely inspiring
in keeping me going and continuing to
use the app to get even better I'm also
about to use the app to start learning
German which I'm looking forward to I
really would recommend Babel to anyone
who watches our show and you can save
25% on a subscription to Babel when you
click the link right underneath this
video